Hallo, mein Name ist Tokös, ich bin hier als Erstentätich und bin heute für Sie zuständig.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Manfred Simon.
Okay, Herr Simon, könnten Sie bitte vor und nach Namen langsamer besteben?
Ja, der Vorname ist Manfred, M-A-N-S-R-E-D.
Und nach Namen bitte?
Der Nachname ist Simon S-I-M-O-N.
Simon, ja.
Ah Simon, wie heiß sind Sie?
Ich bin 75.
Okay, wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie aktuell?
Ja, ich bin so 1,78, steht zumindest in meinem Pass, vielleicht bin ich schon ein bisschen kleiner geworden, weil Alter ist das ja so.
Und ich wiege so 89 kg.
89 kg?
Hi Simon, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für welche Werte haben Sie?
Ach wissen Sie, mir geht es irgendwie seit vielen Wochen jetzt richtig schlecht.
Und ich habe schon ewig lange einen ganz hartnäckigen Husten, der sich überhaupt nicht irgendwie beeinflussen lässt.
Und jetzt ist, ja, ich habe das schon eine ganze Weile, wissen Sie, ich habe mich noch nicht getraut zum Arzt zu gehen.
Aber da kommt manchmal so blutiger Schleim mit raus.
Ja und das macht mir jetzt schon ein bisschen Angst.
Also mir geht es auch eigentlich überhaupt nicht gut.
Also ich bin total schlapp und ich habe keinen Appetit.
Und ich habe zum Beispiel Schwierigkeiten eine Treppe hochzugehen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich musste irgendwie auf einer halben Treppe stehen bleiben und mich festhalten und Luft holen und erst einmal abwarten.
Und das ist überhaupt nicht gut.
Okay, hi Simon.
Sie haben vielen Wochen diese Probleme, oder?
Den Husten habe ich eigentlich schon ewig.
Eigentlich ist er schon jahrelang der Husten.
Aber dass das so blutig ist, das ist erst so 2-3 Monate oder so.
2-3 Monate, okay.
Haben Sie sich bemerkt, haben Sie in letzter Zeit abgenommen?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich ordentlich abgenommen.
Wir passen mit einmal meinen Hosen nicht mehr so richtig die Rutschen alle runter.
Und dann habe ich mich mal auf die Waage gestellt, dann habe ich festgestellt, das wiege ich mich an die Ständig.
Aber ich habe festgestellt, dass ich 6 kg nicht abgenommen habe.
6 kg?
Ja, ich habe immer so 95 kg gewogen und jetzt sind es nur noch 89 kg.
Okay, in welchem Seitraum hatten Sie diese 6 kg abgenommen?
Wie gesagt, ich wiege mich ja nicht so oft, aber ich denke irgendwann so halbis Jahr oder so.
6 Monate, okay.
Und hatten Sie auch Fieber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Keine Nachschweiß und Shit-Death-Rust auch?
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay, verstehe.
Sie haben aber einen langen Jahr Rusten, eine Ausruf und Atemnot wegen Treppensteigen.
Sie haben auch 6 kg abgenommen.
Aber Sie haben keine Fieber.
Ich weiß, ich habe Sie gesagt, nicht gemessen.
Aber fühlen Sie sich nicht fieberig?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Herr Simon, hatten Sie bemerkt, in Ihren Umgebungen ähnliche beschwerdende Menschen,
zum Beispiel sind Sie verheiratet, haben Sie Kinder?
Nee, ich bin verwitvet und meine Kinder sind ja schon lange aus dem Haus,
die kommen mich zwar mal besuchen, aber da hat niemand solchen Lust.
Okay, verstehe. Herr Simon, Sie haben auch keine Appetit, ich verstehe.
Ja, ja, schmeckt ja gar nicht.
Haben Sie auch irgendwelche Schmerzen, Kopfschmerzen, Brustschmerzen?
Beim Husten tut es halt so im Rachen und in der Brust so ein bisschen weh.
Aber nicht so, dass ich Angst zustände habe oder so.
Das ist nur einfach, dass es beim Husten selber fruchtbeanstrengend ist und weh tut.
Normalerweise haben Sie keine Aspenbrunschale, oder?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich habe natürlich jahrelang geraucht und irgendwann recht sich das natürlich.
Wie lange rachen Sie seit wann?
Schon seit ich ein junger Mann bin.
Also das habe ich denn früher geraucht.
Also jetzt rauche ich nur noch ein paar Teufeln so am Tag, so ein bis zwei, manchmal auch drei.
Aber ich habe 40 Jahre lang, habe ich anderthalb Päckchen geraucht am Tag.
Oh, das ist ein bisschen.
Seit wann rachen Sie nur Feichchen?
Ja, ungefähr so zehn Jahre, seit ich im Ruhestand bin.
Ruhestand, seit wann sind Sie Rentner?
Zehn Jahre.
Zehn Jahre. Sie feichen.
Ein bis drei Feichen.
Aber davor rachen Sie ungefähr 50 Jahre, ein halbpacken Zigaretten pro Tag.
Ja, 40 Jahre sagen wir mal.
Aber ziemlich hoch, ja.
Herr Simon, haben Sie diese ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen raucher Mussten, habe ich natürlich immer gehabt.
Ja, klar.
Und so Erkältung habe ich auch gehabt.
Weil das ist jetzt anders, weil das überhaupt nicht besser wird.
Okay, verstehe.
Okay, haben Sie keine Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Ja, ich habe keine Herzrasen, Herzklopfen.
Sie haben keine Herzrasen, Herzklopfen und Herzstoppen, Herzkrankheit?
Na, also mein Vater ist zwar am Herzentrag gestorben, aber ich fühle mich eigentlich,
vom Herzen her fühle ich mich eigentlich nicht so schlecht.
Ich habe eher so das Gefühl, dass es eben der Husken ist, der mich beeinträchtigt.
Verstehe. Okay.
Sie haben keine Herzprobleme.
Haben Sie in der Beine Schwellungen bemerkt, häufig am Abend, beispielsweise?
Ja, in den Beinen.
Eigentlich ist mir das nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, können Sie flachlegen?
Ja, natürlich nicht gut. Nein, nachts muss ich immer mich aufsetzen und ein bisschen husten.
Wegen Husten?
Ja, ich muss auch wegen Wasser lassen, muss ich auch raus, ja.
Aber mit dem Husten kann ich auch nicht gut schlafen.
Okay. Können Sie einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Ja, ich kann auch nicht gut einschlafen, aber beim Durchschlafen gibt es eben auch Probleme.
Okay. Wie viele Mal müssen Sie in der Nacht Wasser lassen?
Klar, ich denke so ziemlich regelmäßig, ein bis zweimal.
Ein bis zweimal, okay.
Okay. Verstehe.
Herr Simon, Sie haben Schlafprobleme, in der Beine Schwellungen husten
und haben bemerkt, Blut geht, Schleim geht, Auswurschen.
Ja, genau, genau, da kommt so so Roter Schleim raus, sie haben.
Aber Sie haben keine Brustschmerzen.
Ein bisschen beim Husten, ja, aber nicht so schlimm.
Okay, verstehe.
Und leider haben Sie schon gesagt, chronische, wegen dieser rachen chronische Lungenerkrankungen.
Aber außer diese Krankheit haben Sie die andere chronische Erkrankungen.
Ja, ja, was halt so alle im Alter haben, mit der Blutruppe ist ein bisschen hoch.
Seit wann?
Ja, ungefähr alles, so 10 Jahre, alles ist losgegangen, als ich nicht mehr gearbeitet habe.
Ja, da ging es dann mit einmal zum Arzt, vorher konnte ich mir das gar nicht erlauben.
Und dann geht man zum Arzt und stellt dann fest, dass irgendwas ist.
Und auch das mit der...
Ne, muss ich dagegen in etwas Tableten, Antipartansife?
Ja, ich nehme da Tabletten, aber ich kann Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen, wie die heißen.
Okay, Antipartansife.
Was noch?
Wie gesagt, mit der Prostata, dann nehme ich auch Tabletten, kann ich Ihnen aber auch nicht sagen.
Und ja, dann habe ich im linken Auge, habe ich grauen Starr, da muss ich regelmäßig Augen tropfen nehmen.
Ja, also bin ich auch da regelmäßig auf den Starr.
Aber linke Seite, planen Sie einen für Sie, eine Operationen oder nur Augen tropfen?
Ne, also ich will keine Operationen, wissen Sie, in meinem Alter habe ich da keine Lust mehr zu.
Ich müsste auch, die eine Bandscheibe ist vorgefallen, da habe ich seit 3 Jahren Schmerzen.
Aber ich habe vor, na, wie lange ist das her? Ja, auch so 10, 11 Jahre, das war damals ja der Grund, dass ich in Rente gegangen bin.
Ja, hier haben auch Bandscheiben vollfallen, seit 10 Jahren.
Ja, einmal ist das operiert worden, aber jetzt will ich das nicht nochmal operieren lassen.
Wie gesagt, ich bin mich zu alt dafür.
Okay, okay.
Und wie läuft diese Bandscheiben-Schmerzen? Haben Sie wieder Rücken-Schmerzen?
Ja, ja, natürlich, klar.
Wieder noch, okay.
Meine Damen und Herren, nach der Operation war es dann lange Zeit gut.
Okay, wissen Sie nicht, ich verstehe Sie, wissen Sie nicht, welche Medikamente ich regelmäßig eingenommen habe?
Nein, ich habe den Zeckel zu Hause liegen lassen, da müssten Sie dann bei meinem Hausarzt anrufen.
Okay, wie heißen Sie Ihre Hausarztname?
Hausarzt ist Doktor Frisch.
Doktor Frisch, okay.
Kann ich nach dem unserem Gespräch, ich rufe erst, wir machen uns das.
Gehen an, ne?
Okay, sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Ja, also ich darf kein Novalvine nehmen, das habe ich mal festgestellt.
Und ich darf auch kein Jod haben.
Da bin ich auch allergisch.
Okay, wie heißt es, wie heißt es, normal wie ist es?
Ja, ich habe da so einen Kribbeln im Gesicht bekommen und das war ein bisschen unangenehm.
Und die Jod-Allergie, nachdem eine Bilkgebinde verfahren, passierte es oder war es ein bisschen unangenehm.
Ja, ich glaube, das war ein Zusammenhang mit der Wandscheibe, dass man das festgestellt hat.
Okay, vor zehn Jahren.
Wie heißt diese Jod-Allergie?
Ja, auch so ähnlich, dass ich so einen Kribbeln in den Händen habe und Jog-Reiz und im Mundbereich, dass ich das irgendwie mit einem akkonomisch anfühle, dass das so kribbelt.
Okay, verstehe. Sie haben schon gesagt, rachen Sie und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also ich trinke jeden Abend eine Flasche Bier zu Feierabend.
Ein Flasche Bier. Und seit wann?
Schon ewig, ja, weil ich hier wachsen bin.
Nur ein Flasche Bier oder mehr?
Naja, früher habe ich natürlich mal ein bisschen mehr getroffen, wenn es etwas zu Feiern gab.
Aber jetzt im Alter, ja, dann wird das alles weniger. Jetzt trinke ich noch eine Flasche abend.
Okay, verstehe. Ich danke Sie, nehmen Sie nicht Drogen, oder?
Drogen? Nein, nein, nein, Drogen nehme ich ganz sicher nicht.
Das ist eine Rhythmästik geblacken.
Sie haben schon gesagt, ihr Vater wegen einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Der ist ein Herzinfarkt gestorben, genau, der war so alt wie ich jetzt.
Wie alt war er, als er gestorben ist?
Er war ja 74, genau wie ich jetzt.
74, aber sie sind...
Und ich bin 75, ja, er war 74, ja.
Und wie ist Ihre Mutter? Ist ihr gesund?
Nein, die lebt natürlich auch nicht mehr.
Die hatte Brustkrebs und ist mit 72 da dran verstorben.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid und mein herzlichen Beilet.
Ja, das ist alles schon sehr, sehr lange her, wissen Sie?
Ja, ja.
Wie alt war Ihr Mutter, als sie gestorben ist?
Sie ist 72 Jahre alt geworden.
Ah, okay, vielleicht. Haben Sie Geschwester, oder sind Sie ein Kind?
Nein, kein Kind.
Ja, sind Sie seit 10 Jahren Rentner, aber was macht ihr sich davor?
Was ich davor gemacht habe, ich war Busfahrer.
Oh, okay, Busfahrer.
Wohne Sie gerade allein, oder?
Im Arm? Wohne ich alleine, ja, genau.
Und sind Sie nicht verheiratet?
Meine Frau ist gestorben auch.
Ah, okay, es tut mir sehr leid.
Darf ich fragen, woran Ihre Frau gestorben?
Ja, sie hatte irgendwie eine komische Infektionskrankheit, ich weiß gar nicht, was das war.
Aber ist auch schon wieder Jahre her.
Ihr könnt vielleicht nicht natürlich Covid, damals keine Covid-Suppe.
Nein, das war irgendwas anderes, ich kann es aber Ihnen nicht sagen, was es genau war.
Okay, mein Beilet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben drei große Töchter, ja.
Aber sie sind alles schon aus dem Haus.
Okay, sind Sie gesund?
Wie viele weiß, ja, sind Sie gesund?
Ich freue mich, das aufzuhören.
Und sind Sie vollständig gegen Corona?
Ich meine ja, mein Hausarzt hat mich da eigentlich, gerade weil ich immer so huste
und weil ich schon so alt bin, hat er mich nicht immer regelmäßig geimpft.
Wie viele Mal gegen Corona und jährlich auch Influenzen?
Die Grippe-Impfung habe ich auch schon dieses Jahr.
Und Corona, ich weiß gar nicht, denke viermal oder so bin ich schon geimpft.
Okay, super.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nee, nee, das geht gar nicht.
Okay, vielleicht.
Haben Sie Traume oder Verletzungen?
Verletzungen.
Okay, fertig.
Herr Simon, ich denke, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen für Sie gestattet.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich würde jetzt natürlich schon gerne wissen, was los ist,
warum ich so schrecklich husten muss, warum das überhaupt nicht besser wird
und was dahinter steckt.
Ja, Herr Simon, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge.
Sie sollten bei uns bleiben.
Ich kann gerade leider nicht genau sagen, ich brauche etwas untersuchen.
Ich denke, Sie haben eine Entzündung, aber ich muss ein paar die andere Krankheit ausschließen.
Deswegen brauche ich körperliche Untersuchungen, labo-Untersuchungen,
Röntgen-Torax-Torax-Tomografie.
Aber natürlich nicht iothaltige Tomografie.
Ja, logisch.
Ich denke, das ist die Langen-Karsin, oder?
Die Branchelle-Karsin, oder die Tüber-Klosung?
Nein, Sie haben schon recht.
Gut.
Aber jetzt machen wir als Absprich, oder?
Erst mal will noch jemand etwas hin.
Es ist, wenn ich richtig in mich erinnere, es ist ein Meinzerfall.
Ja, meint, was ist in das Rheinland-Pfalz?
Also, möchte von den Kollegen, Kolleginnen jemand etwas wissen?
Von Herrn Simon.
Offensichtlich haben Sie sehr vollständig gefragt.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, ich habe fast nichts mehr auf dem Zettel,
was ich noch jemandem erzählen könnte.
Gut.
Ich könnte schon mal so viel zu Manöver-Kritik sagen,
dass Sie das natürlich sehr schön gemacht haben,
dass Sie den Patienten immer schön mit Namen angesprochen haben.
Und was mir auch sehr gut gefallen hat,
dass Sie so variablen Formulierungen hatten,
ist Ihnen aufgefallen.
Das haben Sie bemerkt, oder so, oder?
Das Sie nicht immer, das haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie,
sondern das das schöne, verschiedene Sachen waren.
Hat mir gut gefallen, ja.
Gut.
So, kriegen wir grünes Licht fürs Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
oder Dr. Bubel?
Ja, wir können weitermachen.
Vor Kolleginnen, haben Sie, warum Sie seid,
oder möchten Sie weitermachen?
Ja, Rosa hat Sie ja schon.
Ja.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Eine Kollegin möchte eine Frage.
Ja, gerne.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit auch in Auslander-Gebüli-Bahn?
Ich habe gefragt.
Sie hat gefragt, und ich habe verleint.
Ja.
Ich habe auch eine verleint.
Ja, bitte.
Waren Sie schon mal beim Haarsatz vor Frosterter und da so hungern?
Ja, für die Frosterter war ich natürlich beim Arzt.
Ja, und jetzt, in letzter Zeit,
bin ich nicht bei meinem Hausarzt gewesen.
Der sagt, mache ich es auch mit dem Aufen auf,
weil deswegen gehe ich dann zu gerne hin.
Waren Sie schon mal untersucht für Ihre Lungen?
Zum Beispiel eine Lungen, funktioniert untersuchen?
Ja, aber schon lange her, ja.
Also ich hätte in den letzten 10 Jahren oder 5 Jahren sicherlich nicht.
Okay.
Gut, hier wir go.
Schönen guten Tag Frau Obererzen.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, natürlich.
Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Dankeschön.
Es geht um Herr Manfred Simon.
Er ist 75 Jahre alt.
Er ist 78 Jahre alt und wird 89 kg.
Herr Simon, startet sich bei uns wegen,
seit 2 bis 3 Wochen,
bestehende und im Laufe der Zeit zunehmende,
Blutemoptisi.
Hemoptosi.
Die Auserdenksein bei ihm,
die folgende Begleitzentrum,
Begleitzentrum aufgefallen.
Diesmal belastet abhängige Diesmal,
schon jahrlang husten wegen einer übermäßigen Rachen
und in Appetenz und innerhalb 6 Monaten
circa 6 kg abgenommen haben.
Ja, leid dem Patientin habe er seit langem Nekturi
in Form von beiden,
sowohl Einschlafstörungen als auch Duschelastörungen,
wegen Nekturi und Husten.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Und die Frage, ja, er habe auch wegen dieser Husten
nicht so schlechte, aber Brustschmerzen.
Ja, die Frage nach Herzprobleme, Fieber,
Orthopne, Zowie Orthopne wurden verneinert.
Die Anamnestige angaben, die vegetative Anamnese
ist unauffällig bis auf Obengenemde genantes
Abmisemto.
Anvor Erkrankungen sein bei ihm,
die folgenden Bekannt.
Artälie Liebhaar Tony, seit 10 Jahren,
meine Prostate Hyperplasie, seit langem,
Katarakt, linke Zeit, Katarakt, seit langem
und Discus prolapsus, seit 10 Jahren.
Er wurde einmal wegen dieser Discus prolapsus operiert,
aber leider wieder, wieder holt es,
aber er möchte nicht wieder operieren lassen.
Die Medikamente, die Anamnese leider,
die Medikamente, der Name, die Medikamente,
sein Unbekannte.
Ich muss nach dem Gespräch,
dass ich meine Ausgaben habe,
dass ich eine Anamnese mit Parästhesie im Gesicht
habe.
Ich habe auch eine Anamnese mit
Parästhesie im Handel.
Ich habe auch eine Anamnese mit Parästhesie im Handel.
Parästhesie im Handel und Yukrais.
Er habe diese Allergie während der Bandcheibe
und Vorfall oder Discus prolapsus
eine bildgebende Verfahren gelernt.
Ich denke, eine...
Ah, sogar ist das auch getreten, ja.
Ja, MRT oder die andere.
Er sei gerade seit ungefähr 10 Jahren Renta,
davor aber arbeitete er als Busfahrer.
Er wohne allein, weil seine Frau schon lange gestorben sei
wegen einem Mama-Karsinom.
Er war drei Kinder, er war drei Erwachsene-Kinder
und sie wohnten alle Kinderkrankheiten
und er wohnte alleine.
Er war allein, er war gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten
und er war gegen Covid-19 geimpft.
Er war viermal gegen Covid-19 geimpft.
Er war auch jährlich im Influenza-Virus geimpft.
Die Reise ins Ausland reisen,
Anamnese wurden verleizt, Trauma und Verletzungen
wurden verleizt.
Die anamnestische Angaben deuten am ersten
auf Lungen-Karsinom,
oder Bronchial-Karsinom hin.
Differenzial Diagnostisch-Kombin-Abad,
Verklause, Pynomony,
Lungen-Arterielle im Emboli,
aber ich bin ja nicht sicher, Pynomotorax in Betracht.
Ja, gut.
Was machen die Diagnostische mit den Patienten?
Ich wollte meinen Verdacht bestätigen.
Diagnostisch?
Ja, Diagnostisch.
Als Diagnostische-Massnahme sollte ich
Bronchial-Aspiration nehmen
oder Abschüttrich, die Schleim-Abschüttrich.
Okay, Abschüttrich.
Die microbiologische Untersuchung
für die Hypertgäne auszuschließen.
Zuerst muss ich Bronchial-Torax feralnasen.
Wollten die Patienten nicht erst
körperlich untersuchen?
Ja, natürlich.
Zuerst muss ich köpferliche Untersuchung machen.
Worauf achten die dabei?
Ich muss die Oskultation sehr wichtig,
die Oskultation und köpferliche Inspektion,
die, ich denke, ja, Blässehaut.
Blässehaut? Ja.
Ja, Blässehaut.
Organe mehgalie, beispielsweise metastasiatik,
lungkarsnom, vielleicht hepatosypionomegali,
kann man während die Oblasten finden
und die Kacheksi, vielleicht kann man sehen,
aber er ist nicht kachetik.
Ja, wie viel, immer noch 9, 8, ist nicht so wenig.
Ja, Blutarmut oder Konjuktiva
oder wegen Blutarmut kann man vielleicht sehen.
Genau.
Und Bronchial-Torax.
Danach muss ich mit Kontrast,
mit der Kompetualität Tomografie feralnasen,
aber ich muss beachten und sagen,
keine Iodhaltige Kontraste kann.
Genau, ja.
Und ich muss auch die Tuberculosis ausschließen.
Wegen diese Tuberculosis ausschließen möchte ich
Pipidites machen, Pipidi, auf der Haut,
an der Haut oder im Haut.
Und auch diese Bronchial-Aspirat nehmen
und Tuberculosis, mikrobiologisches,
Tuberculosis, serologisches Test machen.
Leologisches Test, ja.
Und die DiMarre für lungenartige Emboli ausschließen.
Ach ja, natürlich ja.
Pinomotorax, ich habe schon Röntgen-Torax feralnasen,
auch kann man vielleicht Blutgas-Analysis.
Und weiß man ja?
Ja, ich denke, ja, natürlich labo,
Blutgas-CRP, BSK, Tumomarker,
Erhaberach, Prostata, Hyperplase,
deswegen kann man diese PSH-Werte wieder anschauen.
Ich habe eine Methatistäziate für den Karcinol.
Ah, könnte auch sein, ja stimmt.
Karcinol-Ambionic Antigen, PSH-Werte,
Freie PSH-Werte und Alphaphytoprotein
vielleicht kann man bestimmen.
Asstherapie Masname, Zolinvia,
Yenachtem Stadion der Bronchial Karcinol.
Das Bronchial-Karcinol?
Ja, können wir entweder zuerst eine Chemotherapie anfangen
oder Operationale Angriff,
operative Angriff,
die Lage der Tumor entfernen können.
Je nachdem, wo er zuerst.
Ja, nachdem vielleicht Radiotherapie auch unterzutschen.
Die Therapie Zolinvia ist eine psychische Konsil.
Psychiatrische Konsil?
Anergetikum, Erhaber, viel Husten,
deswegen Zolinvia, eine Beta-2-Organistin.
Ja, so sei das Tumor.
Ja, gute Idee.
Auch Asstersystem, vielleicht,
als Auslöser diese Schleimhaut,
aber einmal morgens.
Ja, genau.
Aber auf jeden Fall leider,
schwierige und diese Prognose ist nicht so gut.
Nicht so gut, ja.
Gut, wunderbar.
Sie haben sich wackergeschlagen, würde ich mal sagen.
Sie sind auch eigentlich im diagnostischen
und therapeutischen Bereich nichts schuldig geblieben.
Ja, was Sie nicht gesagt haben,
ist eben das Verfahren der Brunchoskopie.
Ja, ich habe Brunchoskopie, ich habe Aspiration gesagt.
Ach, da habe ich das einfach nicht verstanden.
Ja, aber jedenfalls, dann sieht es wirklich alles vollständig.
Ich denke mal, Sie haben sich wirklich sehr, sehr gut geschlagen
und eine Sache, ja, irgendwas muss ich einmal sagen.
Sie haben irgendwann gesagt, ich brauche etwas untersuchen.
Also, ich brauche eine zusätzliche Untersuchung
oder ich muss sie noch weiter untersuchen.
Dann haben wir das Verb, ja.
Also, ich brauche eine Untersuchung, da brauche ich das Nomen
und ich möchte noch weitere Untersuchungen vornehmen oder so, ja.
Das wäre eine Sache.
Dann, was mir aufgefallen ist, der Mann ist ja alt, ja.
Und wenn seine Eltern mit 75 gestorben sind oder mit 72,
dann kriegt es ja nun schon wenigstens 30 Jahre wahrscheinlich zurück.
Ja, das heißt, da kann man, glaube ich, mit gutem Geburten...
Konservativtherapie vielleicht,
nur konservativtherapie durchführen,
ohne Chemotherapie, oder?
Nein, nein, was ich sagen will,
Sie haben ja in der Familie in einer Nähe
nach den Eltern gefragt.
Und dann hat er gesagt, die Eltern sind gestorben.
Ja, natürlich, logisch.
Wenn ich 75 bin, sind meine Eltern tot.
Dann runter.
Ja, so.
Gut. Und dann passt es aber eigentlich auch nicht mehr,
dann zu einem so späten Zeitpunkt noch Beileid auszusprechen.
Ich würde das nicht machen.
Also, das Einzige, wo man eben sagen kann,
dass der natürlich so ein bisschen vorsichtig ist,
weil er natürlich Angst vor Karzinom hat
oder vom Herzinfarkt,
weil der Vater am Herzinfarkt gestorben ist.
Aber nicht mal, da gibt es so richtig Anzeichen,
dass er sich da besonders besorgen kann.
Ich habe viel zu tun, aber ich rauche 3-mal Pfeife.
Ja, ja, das ist natürlich alles krass.
Und Nikotin haltet mehr als...
Ja, das ist klar.
Wobei das ja vor allen Dingen die Pfeiferaucherei
geht ja auch in den ganzen Mund- und Rachenbereich so doll.
Ja, wenn man nicht nur Puff gemacht, ja, oder?
Wenn man...
Gut, also, wie gesagt, das würde ich jetzt nicht machen,
dass ich da noch...
Kann ich eine Frage?
Wie kann man sagen, er rauche Pfeife
oder er pfeife?
Nein, man kann sagen, er ist pfeifenraucher.
Er ist pfeifenraucher.
Das kann man gut sagen.
Wobei das ja irgendwie so fast eine aussterbende Spezie ist.
Ich glaube nicht mehr, dass es viele Leute gibt, die pfeife rauchen.
Die Zeit lang war das mal sehr angesagt.
Ja, also er ist pfeifenraucher
und dann erraucht 2-3 pfeifen pro Tag.
Man muss ja irgendwie das quantifizieren.
Wobei ich nicht weiß, was die Analogie ist,
praktisch wie viele Zigaretten eine pfeife entspricht,
ob das 2 oder 3 Zigaretten sind.
Und es ist ja immer noch nicht so ganz wenig.
Sie haben Raucher zusammengeschrieben?
Ja, ein Wort.
Interessant.
Dankeschön.
Gut, ja.
Ja, am Anfang im Arztalsgespräch
haben sie sich einmal mit der Zeit vertan.
Sie haben gesagt, er hat seit 2-3 Wochen
blutigen Auswurfs.
Tatsächlich hat er aber gesagt,
er hat das schon seit einigen Monaten.
Das ist noch eine relativ wichtige Sache,
dass man da die Zeiträume hat.
Natürlich ist er ein bisschen stieselig der Patient.
Der traut sich nicht zum Arzt zu gehen,
weil er keine schlechten Botschaften handelt.
Deswegen ist er nie dahin gegangen.
Und jetzt, wo es aber eben zunehmend wird,
die Probleme geht er eben doch mal in die Klinik.
Gut, ja, so viel von mir für heute.
Was möchten die anderen sagen?
Möchte ich jemand noch einen Kommentar abgeben dazu?